most Visions are very poorly articulated
and they sound something like this you
know to be the highest respected
preeminent provider of X with the
greatest possible value you know it's
they're that's what they most mostly
sound like and that's all about you
Vision Just Cause And the reason I
called it a just cause is because it's
external it's a cause so just
that we would be willing to sacrifice in
order to advance towards that cause the
Declaration of Independence all men are
created equal that's a just cause will
we ever get there no we will not will we
die trying that's the point we will die
trying and so a vision is a world that
we imagine that's why we call it Vision
because we should be able to see it like
I have a dream that one day little black
children will hold hands on the
playground with little white children
it's a vision it's something that can be
seen in the imagination it is an ideal
state of the world that we're striving
towards and so a good business generally
does have a just cause a vision of the
future that may not have anything to do
with the product or the service you know
my friend Bob Chapman he uh runs a
company called Barry waymiller it's a
manufacturing company they make large
machines for industry if you ask Bob uh
uh what's your vision for the company
he'll say to build great people to do
extraordinary things
and you'll say to Bob well how do you
measure success then he says we measure
success by how we touch the lives of our
people
in other words his vision happens to be
a vision for how to build the business
actually how to run the business to
build a business that is worth working
for it just so happens manufacturing is
the manner in which they pay for that
Vision but it has nothing to do with the
product
it doesn't have to you know Steve Jobs
had a vision he had a just cause to
empower the individual to stand up to
Big Brother
it just so happened he lived through the
computer Revolution and the computer was
the perfect tool to help advance that
Vision but it has nothing to do with the
product is an idealized state of the
world that you want to live in and you
commit your energy and your and your
business to help build that cause